why was the seventh entry chosen in the
Harry Hole series because it was
probably the best seller does that give
us a possibility for a sequel or
franchise fingers crossed
bet I know right I'm super excited too
I'm even gonna go read the Harry Hole
series now I'm sure there were eight
a woman vanished last night
we just found the body is this the
location of Scandinavia truly what is
gonna give their film its success like
where it's been shot in Oslo going to
the three places yes I know how much you
want this but you can't force the pieces
to fit do you actually think he killed
them Harry Hall has to take a lot into
his mind when he goes deep like goes
through a lot how is that for Michael
Fassbender did that take you somewhere
no you know it was just part of the the
journey I really enjoyed working on this
it was um it was an absolute pleasure so
no it wasn't it wasn't it was fun it was
fun you know the thing is I had so much
information in those books which is a
real luxury you never gets that three
reasons why the Fandango audience have
to go and see the Snowman airy scary
edge of the stairs oh yeah you know we
don't always focus on the attacks in
this particular life it's more to
breathe devices in the consequence also
your imagination
[Music]
[Music]